l'artiste yvelinois sommeil et je vais
bien prononcé a sorti son nouveau single
ce vendredi 4 décembre gm au coeur c'est
un titre qui fait écho à la crise
sanitaire actuelle qui racontent ce que
vivent les plus jeunes les commerçants
tous ces acteurs aussi considéré comme
non essentielles pourquoi at il choisi
ce thème vient tout simplement pas
parler de la crise sanitaire pour faire
comprendre un peu la colère mais de
manière douce puisque sommeil en tant
qu'artiste fait partie des personnes qui
se sont sentis oubliés et donc il a
voulu parler de cette crise tout
simplement pour montrer qu'elle n'a
épargné personne et je vous propose
d'ailleurs de regarder un extrait de
gémo coeur dont le kit sortait
aujourd'hui génération mise à la menthe
génération qui va payer 135 raison
d'être tendre mais tu préfères nos amis
ni
la crise est violente et le dur elle est
plus tous à l'elysée
il ne marche pas dans nos chaussures ne
dorment pas sur le pape est incroyable
son but avec gym au coeur c'est
d'encourager chacune et chacun à agir
pour ne plus subir à cette crise
c'est vraiment un appel à tous les
secteurs où didier a piqué les personnes
qui se sentent donc aussi de se
réveiller et de devenir acteur la crise
et non plus la subir et ce nom de g
moqueur mockingbird il vient de bien
compris donc c'est un oiseau acquis qui
est dans le film qui symbolise la
rébellion justement dans google games et
donc c'est un symbole qui l'a inspiré
ici son message c'est qu'on est tous
moteurs de cette crise sanitaire et
qu'il faut pas absorber les informations
sans les comprendre
même si j'appelle à à comprendre cette
épidémie à comprendre qu'il faut faire
des gestes il faut pas faire des gestes
sans raison et il faut il faut être
acteur et comprendre les choses et de
base se laisser dicter les choses et
donc là son single vient de sortir un
album est en préparation aussi
exactement et sortira il sera composé de
10 titres
il sortira au printemps 2021 et puis il
faut savoir qu'il a lancée sur une plate
forme dont cumule une campagne de
crowdfunding pour pour financer tout ça
et puis il est déjà à plus de 90% de son
objectif quand même
donc s'ils voulaient participer il ya le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
ulule.com etc sommeil pour le nom de
l'artiste
merci justin